a truce between azerbaijan
and armenia is threatening to fall apart
after renewed clashes overnight
azerbaijan has vowed to take revenge
after an alleged armenian missile strike
on its second largest city
gandra the early hours attack killed at
least 12
and wounded dozens more meanwhile
armenia says azerbaijan
has continued to shell populated areas
within the disputed nagorno-karabakh
region
hundreds have been killed since fighting
broke out over
in the region in september
parts of the azerbaijani city of ganja
in ruins
in the early hours of saturday the
destruction of the missile attack was
not yet fully visible but what was clear
was the shock brought here officials say
at least 20 residential buildings were
destroyed during saturday's attack
while most people were sleeping
we have been living in fear for days we
tried to hide from the attack
but that wasn't of any use we are
suffering a lot of pain
right now we can't even identify the
bodies
according to azerbaijani officials the
missiles were fired from two different
locations in armenia
armenian authorities have not responded
to the claims
ganja is the second largest city in
azerbaijan
and lies far from the disputed region of
nagorno-karabakh
since september the hostilities between
armenia and azerbaijan
have escalated to an all-time high a
once frozen conflict
flaring up again the nagorno-karabakh
region lies within azerbaijan
but is governed by ethnic armenians
[Music]
residents there are bracing for new
bombardments
while fearing death from the sky medical
officials are also warning
that the coronavirus is spreading
quickly
amid a war of course our small country
has a growing number
of kovit 19 cases
we don't just like adequate medicine but
have difficulties
isolating and evacuating patients from
our republic
the conditions are especially dire in
bomb shelters
now in these basements many people are
coughing have a fever
many have high blood pressure
here self-isolation is not an option
people in nagorno-karabakh are trapped
between the visible
and invisible threats to their lives
i'm joined now by richard garagosian
he's the head of the regional studies
center
a foreign policy think tank in yerevan
armenia
richard welcome to dw um can you confirm
what isai baijan claims which is
that the missile strikes on ganja were a
deliberate attack by the armenian army
actually no i can't but i can begin with
deploring the indiscriminate violence
the loss of life of civilians on all
sides
this is only a demonstration of the
intensity
of the azerbaijani offenses but there's
also a degree of asymmetry here
we're uh we're in a devastating round of
revenge and retribution
unfortunately this is why an immediate
ceasefire is an imperative
an immediate unconditional cease-fire
unfortunately
turkey and its patron azerbaijan
refused to abide by this offering
opportunity
but in many ways it's the civilians who
bear the brunt of this
war and at the same time we need to
actually
return to diplomacy force of arms is
not a solution richard you're
you're calling for a return to diplomacy
which is totally understandable given
this situation
but it's clear that there's a tit for
tat going on here
um with both sides lobbying accusations
at the other
shouldn't you be able to concede that an
attack that
took place at the night where there are
civilians uh very close by
is in fact not a good look for armenia
oh i would go even further it's
unacceptable let's be honest
it has followed several days of
indiscriminate shelling and bombardment
of civilian population centers
in nagorno-karabakh an expansion of the
fighting into armenia proper but this
second attack on ganja in no way should
be excused
by seeking a military target in other
words
the use of locating military
areas within civilian vicinities is
deplorable
but moreover this has to end now
no side is completely immune from this
devastating cycle downward
hence the need for an imperative of
ceasefire on all sides
a cessation of hostilities immediately i
agree
a cessation of hostilities immediately
however
what do you expect is going to happen
now should we be looking now
uh for a wider escalation of this
conflict
well let me start with the optimistic
note the momentum
is much in the hands of azerbaijan
and the turkish-backed offenses now they
are
taking territory in their advances in
their
fighting with nagorno-karabakh truth i'm
only hopeful that they have seized
enough territory
to satisfy and perhaps herald this as a
victory militarily
to return to sincere diplomatic
negotiations
and i would also expect the armenian
karma side
to concede all the territory that's been
lost
in terms of the necessity to return to
diplomacy
and in this context we may be
approaching a tipping point of
conflict fatigue where the price for
continued hostilities
far outweighs the necessity to get back
to
i think we've lost richard garagosian
but he ends on a good note may we all
hope for conflict
fatigue richard garagosian head of the
regional studies center foreign policy
think tank in rio van armenia thank you
thank you
you